this video has optional audio
description available in settings on
supported devices
i'm with lucy edwards who makes stuff
for youtube and tick tock uh if you've
seen any of the videos about this is how
a blind girl does x yeah i'm the blind
girl i am that i am her
i'm glad you said that not me
and and you've invited me to an airfield
i have and we're going to blindfold you
today till it's going to be interesting
very interesting this is not officially
a competition to see whether a blind
person or a blindfolded person is better
at flying a plane it might be though not
so sort of it is exactly that yes yes it
is i love it this is what we need to do
i'm very competitive we're going to do
this
i have sort of flown a plane for about
15 seconds before i've like held the
control stick and been told exactly what
to do
but that's it i've got i've got no
experience uh i i also have no
experience being blind which seems an
obvious thing to say no fair enough fair
enough yeah i've been blind since i was
17. and uh i just feel like it's
incredible how all of your other senses
take over and i'm going to use all of
those skills today to hopefully like
impart that knowledge on to you i feel
like you have one skill i have the other
and we can work with this tom right
let's go
talk to someone who knows what they're
doing
how how are we able to fly i i didn't i
didn't know this is a thing we could do
what's what is air ability what what are
we doing it
does sound like a dangerous contract but
ability is a charity which exists to
give disabled people regardless of what
that disability is the opportunity to
throw at our aircraft have you ever
flown with a blind person before harvey
we actually have not me personally
um but we've had a few blind people come
through and they they really enjoy it
it's an immersive experience yeah it
really does work how do you adapt the
playmate i'd say our aircraft are
adapted in a few ways we use a
touchscreen
as a
preferred setting for radiation
navigation i because for me with my
hands they worked everything well it's a
lot easier we also have a hand control
which
controls the water pedals apart from
that we have
instructors to develop status techniques
um and anything else we can do
we do can you plummet or like nose dive
no
comes back i'm happy
we're gonna have an instructor right i'm
just it's not gonna be like radio like
there's gonna be someone there doing
like you have control i have control
yeah yeah he qualifies about an hour ago
and you you got your license here as
well right i did so i had a favorite
flying uh bowls are an interesting
becoming a pilot i decided over time
that the interest that way to say
they came here to conquer that failure
and now i've envisioned
being instructor one day when i grew up
so you're going up first yeah i'm not
going to be in that flight
because if i go up and kind of get hints
it's not really going to be it's not a
competition no tips but it won't be it
won't be fair yes not a competition this
is the thing
and and then i'm going up and you're
joining me on that one right yeah and
then the competition truly begins
because i'm going to be like what is he
doing is it better than me is this going
to be you know no honestly good luck
[Music]
watch your head oh yeah so if you sit on
that seat yeah
it's very it smells very leathery it is
leathery
right so i'm going to jump in as well
yeah
very good quality leather are these like
the pedals and this is the control
column okay
so that's right that's left and that's
forwards and that's back backwards yeah
so if we make the plane go down okay
let's make it go up oh right okay see
so if you go like that then we're going
to plum it yeah okay don't do that
right are we ready everyone
okay we're just going to taxi
to
the start of the runway put your feet
forward on the road
so you're gonna take off and then i'm
gonna sort of fly in this guy and then
you're gonna do you're gonna do my
challenge that's right okay cool
so there's a really slight movement
gonna move it really down on my is it
like really
let's see how he gets on it's 2 000
feet like what would you see when you're
looking at the floor like what
will be ants or yeah
here we go
just climbing
[Music]
the smoother it gets oh okay right we
are flying at uh
1800 feet
we're doing 130 miles an hour
okay
let's explain
oh
with that new experience okay i'd like
to keep it in a straight line as
possible okay for the next two minutes
okay yeah
okay
i think this is straight i feel like i'm
going left actually going left hello
what do you think we're doing um
oh my god
okay
i don't even know why i think it's just
because i just can't see
me vomiting i'm like oh
okay
okay ready okay
so we're gonna go to the right first
we're gonna count to three and we're
looking for
30 degrees up back okay
so here we go to the right okay oh one
two three
same thing
one two
okay
one two three
really
all right
okay you feel like your ears are popping
it's such a weird ball
oh i know
i think it's gonna do when it's coming
i'm like
it's anticipation
from now okay
i feel a bit sweaty
i think it was that descent
what could go wrong hey
i was okay because i was screaming but
you were laughing so i was like it's
fine mike's okay it's all good mike is
okay
i just played with lighters did you
will you he just flown the plane
oh it's slightly wobbly that's
terrifying okay okay
because this is this is unnerving now i
can hear things moving yeah i was like
oh my gosh you can feel the red ball you
can smell the leather when you first get
in the plane
i
i do feel like i felt the descent and
the left and right a lot more
than you feel going up but you'll have
to tell me okay
man i i haven't been nervous for a
takeoff in a in a long time it is
oh yeah
i'm not gonna lie i was shaking and i
did i did sweat a little bit
maybe that was too much information
we've just met
oh yeah okay i totally know what you
mean i think day to day trusting
passengers sisters getting on and off
trains other humans that you've only
just met i think it is something to
adjust to um also you know grabbing my
guide dog harness and my
first time with an adjustment oh we're
going we're going are we okay i don't
know all i know is the rudder moved a
lot mike
what are we doing we're just attaching
to the end of the runway all right i'm
assuming that you're going to do the
taking i am going to do it i'm correct
hey here we go ready
you'll be glad to know lucy that
hey we're now airborne are we yeah
wow i know
i
other than a very slight angle change
like yeah slightly i could okay now now
it's a bit of bouncing now we're going
up and down a bit but yeah yeah that's
what it's that's so weird that i felt
that as well
my ears just popped so yeah
but oh there was no difference between
runway and airborne there for me
now we're just climbing out to the north
west we're doing a thousand feet a
minute climb
we're gonna go to two thousand feet
okay that felt like leveling out we're
just left
we're at two thousand feet that's gonna
reduce the power okay
tom just to say every little movement
you do on the control is a lot that's
that's the one thing i the one thing i
know is that i need to make gentle
movements
i've held the planes control stick for
about 10-15 seconds
i was just told whatever you do
slowly gently carefully yeah okay well
we're at 2000 feet now i'm going to
hold you just hold the controls lightly
as lightly as you can okay what i'd like
to do is maintain this heading for me so
you have control i have control
oh
i have no idea i
this is terrifying i have absolutely no
idea
i i don't think so
yes we are we're going down we're going
down we're going down okay well i pulled
slightly back but i don't but not to the
extent that i did i literally plummeted
and screamed okay but you're doing
really really well i feel like we're
feet well done
okay so so the altitude was good but we
started turning yeah we were turning
straight away
okay right so hold it like you're
holding it too tight relax your pressure
okay i'm holding very tight all right
okay so just relax the pressure ready
yep no one two three three stop stop
that was a very fast one two three i'm
never gonna go level again so one two
three stop
so that's turned third degrees both ways
now are we level we are okay so you have
control and i want you to turn to the
right
one
two
three straight
so that's about yeah we're turning about
10 degrees
okay
yeah almost level
and we are going slightly up now okay
oh now i feel like that was that was to
get now that's that's now a level oh
okay so you feel the g quite
yeah but honestly when we were turning
it felt like we were straight i i just
okay oh
right we're now going to uh return back
to blackbush you have control
no you're gonna stay in control
uh black burst this is gold sierra in
the united
we're about three miles to northwest to
rejoin
lucy i appreciate the cheerleading but i
feel like i couldn't tell what was level
like it's it's not a contest mike but
who who won
well for the most exciting descent of
the day
yeah
i think for the 30 degree accuracy turns
lucy did very well right uh i thought
you did very well with your
level even though we turned
almost 180 degrees
yeah but uh yeah it's great i'll take
that i'll i'll take the altitude lucy
thank you at this point i would shake
your hand but i don't feel either of us
are really going to be in a position to
do that
thank you so much tom you're such a good
sport
lovely sky by the way
oh
touchdown i can stay level you can say
straight between us
we're a good pilot between them
you